hey Marvel fans spoilers for Thor -
including the new trailer + spoilers for
the Iron Man 3 post credits scene
Avengers 2 and how Tom Hiddleston's
character ties it all together 2013 is
the summer of awesome and it all begins
now hey everybody
lots of spoilers in a big summer
announcement I'll be talking about Thor
- including spoilers for the new trailer
Avengers 2 the Iron Man 3 post credits
scene and my big summer of Awesome
announcement at the end of the video so
be sure and stick around there are two
big Marvel movies in 2013 including Iron
Man 3 and Thor the dark world Marvel is
using this year to kick the out of
its pantheon of superheroes after
leaving all these characters on a high
note after the Avengers how do you bring
him back to reality when you tear him
down
Iron Man goes all Howard Hughes and Thor
gets himself into a Mexican standoff the
Clint Eastwood would have trouble
shooting his way out of the Thor 2 is a
Vikings
esque World War 2 film Thor finds
himself in a Mexican standoff war with
two other armies one led by Christopher
Eccleston and mr. Eko from lost you
remember him he is super freaky the
title of the movie the dark world comes
from Christopher Eccleston 'he's
homeworld spar Thiem the movie picks up
one year after the Avengers and
Christopher Eccleston has been waging a
war with Thor eventually he gets his ass
handed to him by curse played by mr.
echos character and his Thor's getting
dragged off the battlefield the
Marauders begin to attack Asgard the
only way out of this scenario is for
Thor to partner up with Loki who's been
in prison since the end of Avengers we
already know at the scene between Thor
and Loki is going to be like just
because it's been in the trailer
description that Marvel's released this
doesn't necessarily make Loki his
character good but he will continue to
fight with Thor and the other good
superheroes through Avengers 2 I'll talk
more about that during my Avengers 2
spoilers at the end of the video so be
sure and stick around next up or
spoilers for the trailer
you never see me coming
you remember the first Iron Man 3 teaser
we got shots of all the villains and all
the superhero characters it didn't give
us a lot of story but we did see the
Mandarin we saw the new Iron Man suit
some of the new tech and a few of the
major action set pieces so the Thor 2
teaser that's gonna be coming out next
week will be just like that that means
we'll get some money shots of the
villains will also see Anthony Hopkins
Natalie Portman and Zachary Levi
obviously some of the action set-pieces
will probably see bits of in the teaser
include ACMA hey handiing Thor his ass
the Marauders attacking Asgard and maybe
in a battle with the Dark Elves just
based on the running time of the film
you can expect that the alliance with
Loki where the battle will start to turn
around in the heros favor will probably
come somewhere towards the end of the
first hour of the movie that means we'll
spend the first couple acts of the movie
getting to know Eccleston and ACMA Hayes
dark elf characters and learning about
what this conflict is really all about
if you remember in the first Thor film
Loki referenced all the back doors and
hidden passageways an adze guard they
shot a large portion of the film
underground so obviously a lot of those
scenes are actually on the Dark Elves
homeworld
but you can also expect them to take
place underneath Asgard - the director
of the film is coming from Game of
Thrones so you can really expect this
film to feel much more grounded in Norse
mythology think of it like a game of
Thrones episode with more lightning
bolts and laser beams the jury's still
out on sex position and brothels but hey
the Warriors three have to get shore
leave sometime that brings us to the
Thor 2 credits scene so this is all
speculation but they did shoot some
footage at Stonehenge and obviously Thor
being very ground into mythology is much
closer to magic than any other Marvel
property so you can expect that Doctor
Strange will actually be the
post-credits teaser in this movie a lot
of people were speculating that it might
be Iron Man 3 because of the Stephanie
szostak character connection but
personally I think Thor is a much better
place for Doctor Strange to be
introduced that brings us to the Iron
Man 3 post credits scene so I expect a
lot of these post-credit teasers during
phase 2 to follow the same logic based
on Marvel's release schedule guardians
of the galaxy is the first new
characters coming along next year so I
expect them to be the post-credits
teaser in Iron Man 3
doesn't necessarily mean that Robert
Downey jr. will fly into space and meet
them but that does mean that the idea of
the guardians of the galaxy will be
teased the idea that it's the Guardians
and the post-credits teaser also fits
the matically with Iron Man's character
arc in this film the guardians are all
sewn in to the Avengers 2 villain fan
OHS the Infinity Gauntlet and Loki the
big deal of The Avengers is getting
those infinity gems back from Thanos and
Loki is going to help everyone including
the guardians and new characters ant-man
and Doctor Strange obviously Marvel
wouldn't introduce these characters with
their own films if they weren't going to
be a part of Avengers 2 as well even
though the tesseract or the Cosmic Cube
got taken back to Asgard at the end of
Avengers you can expect that to be a
part of Avengers 2 story as well
including maybe even Thor the dark world
I would even venture to guess that that
is what Marauders are attacking Asgard
for back to Tom Hiddleston like a lot of
character arch you can expect his arc to
come back around full circle although
the exact story isn't known you could
probably expect Loki to try and make a
play for those infinity gems he plays
the mean game of chess and then to be
reminded what real power is well let me
know what real power wants a magazine or
something another big part of Avengers 2
is going to be the Hulk there will be a
future Hulk film it will take place on
earth it's unlikely that it'll be Planet
Hulk just because it's so expensive to
do a movie completely in outer space
although Marvel does want to push
towards a Planet Hulk movie they have to
start small firsts which means that
people slowly and slowly have to get to
the point where everyone else will
basically want to kick him off the
planet so you can expect Mark Ruffalo's
hope to be a much bigger part of
Avengers 2 so big announcement this Thor
trailer and the Iron Man 3 movie are
starting off my summer of awesome I'll
be covering big movie news and spoilers
every Friday so if there's anything you
want to hear about or any big movies
that you want spoilers for let me know
next Friday I'll be talking about the
villains and guardians of the galaxy and
spoilers for star trek into darkness and
star trek 3 subscribe to get that video
I'll also be uploading my Doctor Who
episode 4 video this Sunday and my Game
of Thrones episode 4 video this Monday
in the meantime you can click here to
watch my old Avengers 2 spoiler video
and here to watch the Catching Fire
teaser again thanks for watching see you
on Sunday
for dr. who ie